impossible my left but impossible my
right oh that is a laugh who's the
winner now impossible
I imagine this might be cheating with
this new character but I'm gonna try it
anyway Wow level impossible with
probably the correct character let's go
whoops oh god oh my son oh I didn't even
get a chance kill all get coal mine all
right kill all get coin I do believe I'm
supposed to
yes obstacle course
number two whoa okay then Wow nice
normal little obstacle course not filled
with all kinds of dad well irresponsible
dad run till the old guy with the ax
what ax why do I need an ax I have no
where's the old guy the old guy Oh areas
all right I'm coming for you this time
this time I'm gonna go high in the sky
OOP got below oh come on helicopter
danger run with the innocent little
children I helped it all yeah you don't
need to worry about that this is
horrible
come on pro-survival
come on Oh big swinging ball always whoa
swinging ball
alright this actually might be a little
bit hard okay okay okay okay okay okay
yeah all right
we've lost our helmet but that's okay we
don't need it anyway hey how did that
get your son
all right last time I'm gonna try this
level bike swing what does this even
mean
oh oh wait I don't get it
oh it hurt so bad
didn't tell me that did so what if I
just fall and don't grab the oh I died
colorful robes swing I'm okay I think
yeah no no no no no no no other way
there we go come on just a little more
helicopter test the hobo
anything oh you're butter part don't
mind me I know what I'm doing released
great how do I release great how do I do
that this doesn't look good why my new
standing no how am i doing what am i
doing
Oh Danna you don't look so good over
there this is boring Oh 99.99% him
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you liked the
video and want to see more why not
subscribe today want to help the channel
grow leave a light add it to your
favorites will share with your friends
on Facebook and Twitter thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video
yeah